(audience applauding)
- Oh my gosh.
- Man.
- This is, I don't know if you know this,
I have to tell you this.
We both work for Universal, right?
So did you know that,
I think it's the company's
chief diversity officer
is also named Craig Robinson.
- Craig Robinson, yes.
Yes, yes, yes. I met him.
- [Kelly] You did?
- One time, yeah. It was weird.
It was like-
- Like meeting yourself, like
inception, in another life.
- Like a whole nother
dimension or something.
He's cool. He's cool.
- All right. All right.
So is Michelle Obama's brother.
- Michelle Obama's brother.
- I found that out too.
- Craig Robinson.
- Yeah.
It's a great solid name.
- Yeah, I-
- Maybe not super unique
since everyone has it.
- Clearly.
(Kelly and Craig laughing)
- Has it ever caused a problem for you?
- Yeah, actually, yes.
So I was dating a girl one time
and she called me up crying
because she thought that
the Craig Robinson they
used in the article,
there was an article
and they had my picture,
but they had Craig Robinson
divorced and remarried,
and she was my girlfriend at the time.
So she thought that I-
(audience and Kelly laughing)
And I'm just, and I just was laughing and-
- [Kelly] She was not.
- Well, we broke up.
- "We broke up".
(audience laughing)
She was like, he is a liar!
That's really weird.
Like, get your-
Well, I mean, whatever facts
are lied about all the time.
- Yeah, somebody sent it to her
then she just, you know.
- Yeah.
- Catastrophized it.
- Oh, that sucks.
Well, you have lived
a few different lives.
So we talked about your work
as a music teacher before,
but is it true that you
were also a bouncer?
- Yeah. Yeah. I was a
bouncer in the nightclub.
This is while I was
teaching at the same time
and getting my master's
degree, but I was a bouncer.
I did nightclub.
- That's awesome.
Doing all of that at once.
Do you have any crazy stories, like?
- Not, not really. I was-
- 'Cause people get drunk
and make poor decisions.
- Yeah. I was the guy that
went to get the bigger guys.
(audience laughing)
- There's a bigger dude.
- I was like,
"they fighting over there!"
(Kelly laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh my goodness.
- I was a bouncer slash tattletale.
(Kelly laughing)
- I love it. I love it.
Well you've done well
for yourself since then.
I love that, a masters
as well, that's cool.
You've got two NBC shows.
One is "Killing It".
So what's that one about?
- "Killing It" is about
a guy named Craig Foster.
I play Craig Foster and-
(audience laughing)
- That must have been a
hard name to lean into.
- Yeah, I had to really stretch for that.
But he'll do anything
for the American dream,
including battle invasive species.
So that was the first season.
Next season, we have season two.
Anybody watch "Killing It" out there?
Check it out.
(audience cheering)
That's not what the numbers say,
but you can check it out.
- I just love it.
I just love it. Wait, is there a drill?
Is that a drill next to you?
- [Craig] Yeah, that's a-
- [Kelly] A drill and a snake.
- A drill and a snake.
Yeah, I was a snake hunter.
I snake hunted for cash
as a competition they do in Florida
and a python hunter, yeah.
- Is it a real thing they do?
- It's a real thing they do.
I think this year they gave away a ATV.
Because you know, the python
population is outta control.
So they hire people to, yeah.
Or they get people in the contest
and so yeah, we did that.
- I know a lot of
hillbillies that would go
make some money hunting down some pythons.
- [Craig] Oh for sure.
- Yeah.
All walks of life come.
- Yeah, I was gonna say
that must be just like
a great viewing party.
(Kelly and Craig laughing)
It's like, who's showing up?
That's amazing.
So what's the wildest thing
you've ever done for money
that you can say on television?
- Oh, well-
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- We all have those moments.
- Stand up comedy.
- That's the wildest thing?
You know, I guess do
you handle like hecklers
or anything like that well?
Like especially when you first started.
- I've had some good moments.
- Yeah?
- [Craig] Against a heckler.
Yeah.
- Do you- I kind of love,
even when someone at a show
like I'm singing, they
like, they just get loud,
they're excited, maybe
had too much to drink.
I love playing with those people.
- Right, right.
And you gotta like, you know,
kind of feel 'em out, see if they're-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like with you
or against you.
'Cause some peoples are good.
- or an angry drunk,
- Somebody's just like, I love you!
Like, I don't think I love you too.
And some people, yeah,
just- they wanna be part
of the show and you gotta-
- [Kelly] pipe down.
- Let 'em know they're not.
- Yeah
(Kelly laughing)
It says Craig Robinson.
Is your name Craig?
It might be Craig Robinson.
- It might be Craig Robinson.
- [Kelly] You don't know.
(Kelly and Craig laughing)
I heard that you had to cancel
a standup show last year,
so what happened?
- Oh, oh, oh, yeah, yeah.
It was a active shooter.
It was in North Carolina.
There was an active shooter guy came in
and he came in and he had a gun.
And luckily it was between shows,
so they had just seated like one table.
And then he came in there.
He waved at the front of the
staff and some of the patrons,
anybody who don't want to
get shot you know, get out.
And then they got us to safety.
- Does that scare you at all?
Like to get back in there and do it?
- No, I don't worry about that.
- [Kelly] You don't let fear-
- That was on one time thing.
And he actually was coming
to see another show.
So I don't think I was targeted,
but like I said, I felt
more than safe being there.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- You know,
it was just the fact that he had arrived.
- I love that you don't let fear drive you
or keep you from doing something you love.
- [Craig] Well, now.
- Yeah.
But yeah, I'm sure that night it was like,
maybe I should change vocations.
Okay so I hear you seem to find
a piano wherever you travel.
Is this a thing you love to do?
- Well, I've never met
a piano I didn't like.
- I like that.
- [Craig] Yeah.
- That's 'cause you're good at it.
- Every once in a while I'll be somewhere
and there'll be a piano somewhere-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Craig] And I'll pop up and sit down.
Yeah. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Especially the bar
at the hotel you're
staying at or something.
I feel like they always have one.
- [Craig] Yeah, that's happened for sure.
I think that was in Austin.
- Austin, Texas?
- Yes, yeah.
- Oh man, they probably loved it.
- Oh yeah, yeah. They came
around and was you know,
being silly.
- [Kelly] It's like
Music City there.
- We just did a whole
little show right there.
- What's the best,
do you have like the
most memorable moment,
something that's happened like that?
You just sat down and
something cool happened?
- Oh.
(Craig laughing)
I was at this party and
Mick Jagger was there.
- [Kelly] What?
- And it wasn't like
Mick Jagger happened to be there.
It was a party, we were doing this movie
"Get on Up".
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And they had a party at
this guy's house somewhere.
We were in Mississippi
and Mick Jagger's one of the producers.
But then he got around the piano,
was just singing tunes with us.
- [Kelly] That's crazy.
- It was amazing.
Wish I had that picture for you.
- Oh my God, I swear, I
would've laughed while singing.
Like, what is life?
- [Craig] Oh, it was, yeah, it was just-
- [Kelly] I love moments like that.
It's like a movie.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was on a cloud.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
Have you always been into music,
like since you were a
kid, is it something-
you connect with.
- [Craig] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My mother was a musician.
So she was first chair cello
in like, high school.
- Oh, I love the cello.
- And she was a minister of music
and she sings like an angel.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So music was in our blood.
She was singing to us and playing
for us when we were in the womb.
- That's so cool, growing up
in that kind of household.
Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Is that, do you feel
like you connect with her.
- And you'd have big Christmas parties
with everybody singing and-
- [Kelly] Yeah
- Singing harmony and all that.
- I love that. I know a lot
of people that did grow up
there in the music
industry and they grew up
with families that were
super musical like that.
I wish I had grown up like that.
That's so cool.
And just, I loved harmonies.
Harmonies are like my favorite thing.
Like, 'cause I always
had to sing the lead.
- Me too, me too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Kelly] It's fun to find it.
- I don't always have to sing the lead,
but harmony, it's nothing like it.
- I know
- [Craig] It's nothing like it
- It's so special to
connect with somebody.
Like, we don't think about it enough,
but like when someone's making a sound
coming out of their body and, like
you do this note that
kind of vibes with them.
It's just that feeling and
that energy is so special.
I feel lucky that we get
to be a part of that.
'Cause not everybody can find pitch.
(Kelly laughing)
- And all the time
we're like, you'll sing and
then they'll hop onto your note.
- [Kelly] They'll help you out.
'Cause they're-
- So you go to another note
and they'll follow you to that note.
- Oh my God, that
happened to me at a show.
Somebody was like, let's do a duet.
And I was like, awesome.
And we got on stage and I was like, oh no.
'Cause like, they couldn't-
every time I was doing harmony
they'd just start singing
what I was singing
and I was like you can't do that
because, somebody's gotta
hold down the-
- That's called unison, yeah.
- I know, but somebody's
gotta hold down the melody.
I'm like singing alto over here.
Anyway, it was interesting.
I think I realized at a younger age,
I was like, oh every singer can't do that.
I didn't know that.
It's interesting to find out
in front of 15,000 people.
(all laughing)
But we've got some of your friends
up in Blake's box seats right now.
The Harlem Globetrotters, what's up y'all?
(audience cheering)
- Zeus and Moose, what's up?
So what is it that you're
doing with the Globetrotters?
What's happening?
- We're doing a show,
it's called "Play It Forward".
And it's showcasing the
Harlem Globetrotters
and the amazing work they do
in the community, in their communities
and throughout the world.
And you know, showcase their talents
and they do some crazy stunts.
But it's really just
showing their whole light
'cause it's such a-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- A complete package.
They're not just people who beat up
on the Washington Generals, you know?
(Kelly laughing)
They're phenomenal people.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And this show
highlights that.
- I love it.
(audience clapping)
I love the "Play It Forward".
That's so cool.
Are you into basketball?
Are you really into it?
- I'm into basketball, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] I just got
into football like heavy.
Like I love it a lot now.
I've become one of those crazy,
the people that say "we",
like I'm a member of the team.
- Right, right, right, right.
- So I'm looking forward
to getting into basketball.
That's my next sport to get into.
Who's your team?
- I'm from Chicago, Bulls.
- Okay, the Bulls, okay.
Is that Jordan?
Is that where Jordan was?
- Yeah, yeah, for sure.
- Yeah.
See, I know things. I know things.
(all laughing)
Yeah, yeah.
I'm Mavericks 'cause I'm a Dallas girl.
- Okay. Oh.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Y'all are killing right now.
- [Kelly] Okay, are we?
- Y'all are killing it.
- I don't know.
- Luca.
I'm gonna get into it.
- Y'all got Luca.
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- He's the man.
- Okay. All right.
Well we've got a basketball
game next everybody.
Let's take a quick break.
More with Craig Robinson
and the Harlem Globetrotters
when we get back.
(audience cheering)
Stay right here.
(upbeat music)